[Music]
back up my broccolini get your life
together
I'm not touching
they're a thing like inside his workout
or so what are we starting are we
starting yet we're up
well [ __ ] didn't know did it no we're
admiring that man's body
it's impressive a lot of hard work I
love the comments people like oh if I
was on it stuff I'd look like that no
you want it
no you wouldn't though well you would
have you ever done steroids before no I
want to really I wish I would have never
did them do you think people were doing
them hell yeah really yeah not a fact
eyes I thought tested positive
afterwards well what broke you got to do
them then because um now not so much
yeah I yeah I guess you did them right
yeah I did Ambrose snapped
oh yeah I was pretty jacked men you
really yeah dude what do you think I'll
say yeah like you have Whoopi Goldberg
genetics yeah like you're not built like
[ __ ] Whoopi Goldberg you feel like
[ __ ] whoopee cushion yeah like you
don't have Meg Ryan's frame never shirt
oh look at that dude dang bro welcome to
that jack nation sorry welcome them
Deckard [ __ ] you are pretty look at
that look if it's about the water click
on that oh yeah Jack Ryan
that's Jill's brother baby hey were you
just putting needles in your ass
huh or we taking pill look at me right
there dude that's my planning to be a
trainer too not your cut sick
thanks you were just doing the damn
thing up I don't feel like were you I
feel like you'd be real aggressive just
a loose cannon bro I remember it off
take and then just be like [ __ ] in the
bar just like you're ready to go at that
moment I remember eating a shot glass
one time at the bar down the shot Reagan
couldn't find a place to set the shot
glass down
yeah man I just I can't believe you
didn't do if here's the thing if other
people were doing it you didn't stand a
chance
well the one guy who did test positive
for I beat him you did yeah Wow he was
jacked yeah you can just do thing like
you can just pick up stuff so much
easier really what was your were you
just were you roid rage in like were you
his no no I remember I was kind of like
I couldn't build like a card house
because I was kind of [ __ ] high
strong yeah no I wasn't on I always put
some bootleg stuff I think I think I was
on something I've been made locally at
one point boil something I was on had
like a cinnamon base to it I remember
because I do my hands smell like
pancakes that's a good problem there's a
flare-up if I go for a jog neighbor
valley life Rose do you I can't believe
it and do any bro cuz if I can afford it
what bro it's $100 you're thinking I'd
pay less yeah I know
no you're thinking the Gold's Gym roids
but in the UFC because they still have
testing you to have them high-end
designer steroids I can afford it oh
really guys good I just got it oh wow
how much is that high-end stuff on one I
don't know but if you have to ask you
can't afford it yeah that's true
chin you ever done steroids not like
Chumlee a [ __ ] bloodsport if you do I
could see you doing something brick
don't hit back zahramay yeah you look
like a mannequin azar Amanda you look
like a mannequin that [ __ ] went rogue
okay a mannequin in the in the Chinese
female lesbian section of Burlington
Coat Factory
who's like you know what I'm gonna
[ __ ] I'm changing things up I'm gonna
start a [ __ ] business did you look
like a billionaire but we have no idea
how you made your money just super
secretive Channel yeah you look like a
secret billionaire you own all the PF
Changs
yeah you look like Paul Franklin Chang
general Tao its general so oh there's me
right there look
dude that chin that could be you bro oh
oh you're the tits on chun-li there
right and who is that man with that
chun-li
his name's bolo yeung I think beautiful
man huh yeah Wow look at his pectoral I
saw my Gold's Gym one time when we're
young right I grew up in Venice in the
summers and we my brother saw him and we
that was our favorite movie Salt Flats
Burton 1000 times and we saw him and my
brothers like oh [ __ ] this John Lee and
he's like in sweats like work out my
brother goes hey man we're big fans and
I don't know if you just didn't speak
English or what but Dean would
acknowledge just kept walking am I
really this man I'm glad Van Damme
whooped your ass that's what he was like
nice dang that was pretty gangster also
very rude cuz I don't think he
understands English Van Damme man Van
Damme
that's crazy I can't believe you guys
said that to him at a Gold's Gym what
we're two nine year olds are bad Gold's
Gym if they were selling their bodies
pumping iron bro pumping Arnold there's
nothing lower than an 80 pound dumbbell
we all doing just hanging out bro you
guys probably had hardly enough energy
to push the button on the water fountain
is tough our data take us in that in the
summer
really [ __ ] was sweaty and Vantage's
dudes yeah you know we grew up there in
the summers do you know JP lost when
he's probably around the same age
he's from Venice is he from Venice yeah
I'm sure we ran similar crowds you feel
me um I thought he was from your neck
the woods he play Tulane oh that's right
yeah LSU's words bro what's up that's
crazy man y'all hurry I think people are
excited you know I'm happy to see
obviously everybody's kind of fired up
to see a white guy get a prize you know
it's been a tough couple years huh but I
think he seemed like a stand-up guy you
know but I think we need more vietze out
there we need more Mexicans yeah and
football in every sport or just in
Awards uh yeah maybe but I think we need
more I want that Mexican basketball guy
you know it's just not for them you know
huh that's not for them Hector you know
sir you shoot a 6-point or actor ally
you know but that's what we're up Hector
just lobbing six pointers wearing
Dickies boy we City haha [ __ ] your lab
city bro yeah tomorrow get on my
shoulders my shoulders old yeah
but that's what I'm saying bro we need
that kind of element I think would add
just to mix it up yeah man I'm just I
get I love basketball it's great but
it's also gotten a little bit like
everybody is the same
everybody's a six foot 11 guy you know
you mean black guy semi semi I'm not
sure unless you're European if you're a
white kid in the United States trying to
get to the end it ain't happening
homeboy yeah you can be an assistant
coach have men dude you play that d3 be
the good white boy shoots threes in the
corner yeah we're out there yeah you'll
be playing for Radford right yeah but
yeah I would just love to see I think
because Mexicans have such a good
they love basket but you know there's
such basketball fan huh I think so a lot
of Lakers fans yeah I thought it's more
well those those more baseball and
boxing for the Mexicans from my nicer
Joe do you know Kent what are you not
football
they don't really [ __ ] with footplant
really maybe they love the Raiders yeah
cuz I'm from the Bay Area every single
Mexican I grew up with loved the Raiders
I'm not talking like real Mexican like
from Guadalajara
they're not your bike kid what do you
think of Derek Carr
oh yeah no yeah you took him out zoo
owners that's what I'm talking about
those guys it got a whole zoo Ponzi
scheme you try dragging me into a dude
and I was into it for a second
chin low do you [ __ ] it look it's a oh
just looking [ __ ] sweet dude yeah you
look I got straight-up hit like a bro
but you look like you're in the witness
protection program
you look like a hidden character in
Mortal Kombat [ __ ] you look like
somebody whose main job on earth is to
keep a secret
[Laughter]
trying to keep lights on well it's time
of year to do something about it it is
that time of you timeout trimming that
Bush
well whatever man I mean I don't know
who they're electing right now but trim
you tree
yeah trim your Bush dude from your trunk
brooch from that baby shrub you know ya
know what guy who tried to uh smoke his
bean this one time at the park he pulled
his whole body up over us and then tried
to put his wiener in his mouth and light
his nuts like a bong yeah like a uh yeah
like a dong yeah like hell how did it
work out they called him somebody called
him thank God that's gonna end it bad
don't be that guy though don't be that
guy trim your balls trim your balls all
right with no Nick's or cuts he used
manscape a lawn mower 2.0 to groom those
hairy nuts order now and get it shipped
for free on Santa's sleigh Santa this is
me
I'm Santa he doesn't want to see any
frickin bushes he's just dropping these
manscaped 2.0 packages to all the houses
yep Santa what am i got one for her chin
you really yeah oh yeah a lot of women
need that neck touch-up you know or get
them get them hairy tooth on my face too
what yeah don't use the same trimmers on
your faces you turn your balls that's
just nasty
that's a psychopath did I just have this
room
bro who would trim his junk over about a
television you know when they had
marathon TV program I can't do that man
and mask a perfect package 2.0 includes
a crop preserver alright and then also
they give you a pair of manscape boxer
briefs or your junks feeling fresh all
day tis the season to manscape so get
yourself your dad your brother your
grandma your hairy sister the mask a
perfect package 2.0 yeah get you up
thick cousin something dude
rare wrap that clown up yeah I don't
leave them out get 20% off in free
shipping with code cats k 80s at
manscaped calm your balls will thank you
get 20% off and free shipping with code
cats at manscape Thomas K 80s at
manscape calm that's 20% off with Free
Shipping at manscape comm use cats clean
up your nuts make Santa proud this year
ho ho Zelena cousin nuts yeah oh look
I'll tell you straight up man if I go to
my frigerator and I open the freezer no
joke probably about 16 pounds of meat
comes falling out of that bastard
you know why get that meat that meat
fridge get up well because one of my
shelves is on level in there and I
loaded it up with the meat bro and that
meat is from butcher box and that's high
quality beef bison or you open up my
freezer it sound like a whole zoos
falling out hmm it's a meat slip and
slide get you some meat in your mouth
every month butcher buck chips a curated
selection of high-quality meat right to
your home all the meat is free of
antibiotics and hormones none of that
man each box rate for this ninth 11
pounds of meat for your mouth you don't
get that pounded meat baby get that
pounded meat pack that meat in your
mouth a lot of call crunk about butcher
blocks dude yeah you don't rain or oh it
isn't no brainer meat
shut your brain down yeah do whatever
you got to do take your brain out of
your head and fill your head with
straight-up meat it's the best meat ship
right to your door a lot of people don't
know where meat as well here's where it
is right there bro talk to me for your
ass [ __ ] some way
with butcher box you get the highest
quality meat around for just six dollars
a meal that's what it comes out to and
they even have free shipping nationwide
Alaska Hawaii not so much right now you
can get two pounds of ground beef and
two packs of bacon ready full free play
us off your first box just go to butcher
box.com / k 80s use promo code cats at
checkout and that's grass-fed beef daddy
ain't and that's finished beef a lot of
time you see somebody that got that
unfinished beef you know that
uncircumcised cattle not up in doing
that we talking about this is finished
beef free-range organic chicken heritage
pork brother this is third fourth
generation pork prize-winning Pig baby
meat for your mouth that's butcher
box.com / Katz throw some [ __ ] meat
in your mouth and your cousin's mouth
Brooke gang [ __ ] damn we got a bunch
well I'm just got all these hoes
we got one it's just not yeah well hold
on bad looking we go boy she's a cutie
left or right right oh snap it eat a
candy her name is Harley nicknamed
Carlito with the Tito's o4 knockers
that's her thing huh Long Beach
California single and ready to chain
rule Oh LBC what she likes a little lo
mein you feelin that [ __ ] what's up brah
yeah you guys want to FaceTime her huh
Wyatt Channing here is she into it she's
into it I wonder if me and Theo should
do it separate first and then oh I want
chin and what's her name Tito knockers
name is Carley Carley we'll call her hot
car so I want chin and Carl to meet in
person dude we don't want them meeting
video you don't want that [ __ ] let us
let us be your guide chin let us take
you to pleasure town what we're just
gonna call her you ready yeah face time
nervous about to do it in there okay
look like you just got home from work
and I look I got us made-up iris okay go
on
let me ask like I'm busy all right taxes
this year dude it's gonna be a thick
summer how's it going you are oh and
what go ahead
don't let Brielle Craig do your friends
what's your do your friends call you
Carl
no what's your nickname what's your fave
I love Carl and have you ever do you are
you happy that it's winter talk about
the smooth operator Jesus Christ I'll
take it from here
oh you are you a letterman at a funeral
parlor dude you look like a french toast
buster dude jumped out of Mario Kart how
about you take a back seat for a second
what about Jude Law shirt is from the
[ __ ] meg Ryan collection I'm sorry
I'm sorry about my friend yeah forget
about the winter question Carly thank
you for your time today we understand
that you responded to genders because we
have a young male here that we are
looking to find love for your man this
is off to a bad start
are we still breaking up was just Theo's
voice yeah I figured yeah it's just his
speech not a big deal homeschool so
anyway um so what made you reach out to
maybe go on a potential date with our
friend chin hair oh so you're single
ready to mingle yes yeah can you use a
term that's not from 1970 Brendan hey
real quick
ask her about the weather
Dorcas mellorak it's a seven winter
delinquent let me talk for a second yeah
go ahead
good afternoon um do you um have you
ever spent time around uh someone like
chin before him evasion oh this is not a
good start
what's your usual bad counts you know um
what's your usual type like what type do
you go for like a variety but mostly
white guys mm-hmm what about off-white
okay and do you what do you how done dog
how has your experience been on the
dating scene has it been a bit of a
nightmare or I mean you're a pretty girl
thank you I mean but that's not your
fault
I hope not but you also enjoyed do you
like being single I mean it's kind of
fun right
periods of it but yeah I think it's fun
I mean you don't have to worry about
yourself well what was the last date you
went on are you a serial dater do you
date a lot no no I merely go on and
where do you usually meet these men like
which one like yeah are we talking like
tinder we talking bumble FarmersOnly are
you on FarmersOnly I knew it I know it
good there's a lot of people infiltrated
it it's not it's not only farmers and
the problem other people are getting on
there yeah do you like to go to the gym
you said what else do you enjoy doing
ma'am young let it yeah yeah yeah
sorry yeah sorry she's young lady yeah
besides the gym I mean what work go to
gym friends concerts and yeah and you're
headed to work now I'm going to be
shortly yeah
and where are you working these days I
work at an advertising agency gotcha hmm
sounds professional and and that last
date you went on what did you guys do
like you ever give us the idea of the
date you went on then you got what oh
I'm sorry
the line cut out and I have you ever
made love to a kind of a troubled kind
of Asian guy made love to H to an Asian
gentleman decent guy okay your first one
and chin likes this chin likes this and
do you think that you have do you think
that a lot of Asian guys hit on you
usually or do you feel invisible to them
or what do you feel like but you
probably don't encounter a lot of Asians
I'm just gonna go on a limb but you got
some flavor with that yeah I could see
that you got some flavor with that nose
piercing so I'm assuming you get all
sorts of comers what sorry my friend is
uh ha not very wise look let's be honest
with each other how far do you think you
see you and Chin's future going can they
start a date first dude and then take it
from there no one knows we have no idea
yeah he's like a missing person that's
alive yes that's exact
sorry my friends had his own issues of
dating um yeah I think you guys need God
Aten feel have you ever seen chin do you
know what he looks like
yeah and your and your friend submitted
you for this yeah
and does your friend what did she say
you you're gonna love this guy or this
guy seems like a real kind of a sort of
a hero like a middle-aged hero or what
did she what did she say and what
college did you go to oh no hell yeah
LBC girl lbst actually she's in the LBC
though it's awesome you're brave I like
your attitude I like your attitude to
what would be a perfect date for you I
love red wine okay Jen write this down
okay done a winery mm-hmm
I see nap in your future okay came out
here while he just wrote down Red Vine
so if you get a bunch of movie kandi
people know what's going on let her
finish her date though so Kate has more
so Reza what else sorry I mean I'm
pretty so talkative person yeah I think
that like not like a movie where you're
just sitting there and quiet yeah that
makes no sense I prefer like activities
like fun thing
mm-hmm okay competitive okay I'm well
that's kind of just open for whatever
easygoing yep easygoing you ever gonna
[ __ ] fights before no and I look I'm not
saying it's legal everywhere but I'm not
saying it's also not Ottawa his change
yeah a lot of we're asking for it yeah
you can get far after that as well yeah
yeah could be a nice night
well look we would love to treat you
guys to a nice night out wherever that
is and do something special for you guys
and we don't know what that's gonna be
exactly yet but we have a nice budget
for it and we want to you to do
something fun if you're willing to take
our friend out who also is willing to
take you out I like your style girl your
boys always like this or do you have a
cold I like yeah yeah girl we all do a
blow or anything like that or what were
you guys up to
[Applause]
it was for my company party drugs too or
just alcohol I gave you fancy drugs at
all do you partake in any drugs
I like your attitude
Wow yeah you seem like a great lady seem
fantastic uh if things don't work out
can you and chin I I got a friend who
looks like meg Ryan that might be a yeah
leave me alone Brendan I'm throwing you
alley-oop Sarah dude and you slept no
you seem like a great guy you seem
awesome well I think maybe you send us
some date you're available we'll get
with chin schedule hon let me check yeah
he's available
I shall then we'll take you from there
and let me know yeah where you going
damn family chap he'll yeah what island
girl what island
yeah I hate when people ask me what now
he's good you get back from Hawaii and
then we'll take some time in January
does that work yeah you know thanks
thanks for being such a good sport about
this yet Carly thank you so much for
calling you seem like a lovely person
merry Christmas to you yeah I'm a fan
Carl Merry Christmas
Jesse's cute good yep
well yeah I guess we don't want you to
see her we want you to be a unique man
yeah I'm telling you jeez she an
attractive lady check attractive great
personality - fantastic that really was
piercing sexy reminded me of uh
wonderful people in the world man you
got a chance Chan if you [ __ ] take
care of yourself you idiot I don't know
if he has a chance but we're sorry I
don't mean that bro I'm just thinking
about myself I think you have a chance
like Rudy had a chance you know I'm
saying like you're really gonna have to
the rabbinic situation what yeah oh you
have no confidence in this [ __ ] dude
this guy looks like ya not hear you I
hear you I hear you I hear you man this
guy looks like something a woodpecker
would attack she knows a chance like
Vincent apollyon a chance you I'm saying
it's gonna take a lot of work and some
tough breaks but we can get there cat
what do you think let's sit let's let's
uh venture out into the Far East here
and get a quote from cat what do you
think about chin and then the potential
lady there Carly Oh Carly is a she seems
like such a nice girl genuinely really
nice I think it would be good fit
fortune you do yeah if Jim puts himself
out there properly yeah she's pretty hot
too that's very pretty real hair very
pretty attractive nice head it looked
like I mean all we could see it was her
head and arms kind of in a little bit of
her torso but definitely nice neck nice
body nice name I don't know the body
yeah yeah but I'm sure about he's great
so from the LBC I kind of like that for
chin as well yeah she probably defend
herself
chin did you hear she like all we know
she likes red wine
she's down if you're gonna do a bunch of
drugs too
it's own and that's about all we know
out of her she likes activities yeah Jen
pretty broad so what do we do we send
them on it is what I'm wondering I think
I hike a nice hi hey goddamn you're off
on this a hike Chinon shorts have you
ever seen Chinon shorts no one has ever
ever chilly put on some [ __ ] low-cut
shorts going on a hike with this broad
we ain't doing that I feel like maybe
some sort of concert intimate concert
you guys go she's drinking red wine chin
nose music you know I'm saying she's
like oh girl that's that Gino what's
this boom you're just a dusting
what's this boom dinner I don't matter
you're going with this why does dinner
come out like that cuz an egg roll do
for God your mind is crazy egg from an
ostrich so is a large egg I'm just
spitballing ideas here you guys go to a
nice Korean barbecue that's Jin's
identities he knows all the barbecue
spots you take your adult place downtown
Qin right probably don't dress exactly
like that but I'll figure that out you
have any ideas dude so we go to Korean
barbecue then we go to a nice intimate
kind of concert and then after that but
she said she's down for fuff that's all
I know
whatever that means I don't speak that
language some ACK it's a regional treat
you delinquent all I know is for our
first shot he's in dude dude I'm sorry
I'm leaving paddy from million-dollar
matchmaker now bring up Patti Stanger if
we can what happened to that lady I saw
her once you tried to set me up with
somebody really yes it leave me alone
bro you do look like pieced anger bro
don't mean every kind of like similar
shut up Big Ang member she died big
hands yeah became whose began from Mob
Wives oh oh yeah with them long tits
yeah I remember of course she died dude
let me guess skin cancer she the Staten
Island's on her chest bro she had some
long titties dude Coney Island tips yeah
I'm [ __ ] L trains on her support the
podcast look man it's that time of year
brother bells will be ringing King about
things around me dude you know what you
should do you should give your I've been
mean to tears
[Music]
Wow alright remake you don't have that
on my Christmas track alright man we'll
need all dude who did this mix it who I
don't know you have maybe chin did but
dude I've been thinking about what you
give yourself this year for Christmas I
think you need to step your brain game
up I think you should give yourself the
gift of audible my brain hurts do my
brains to know this feels like it's just
somebody just is trying to hide my brain
inside of just uh just inside of my own
body or my own butt yeah sometime feel
like somebody's playing freeze tag in my
brain no one else to play with such as
frozen so I like definitely it's like to
get all the time when you're thinking
about something I see like that spinning
circle that I see them act up just like
downloading it yeah here yeah it's cool
man it's really chicks dig it
yeah legs do dig it man Auto Bowl is the
best time right now you get fifty three
percent off your first three months I
use three titles every month one
audiobook and two exclusive audible
originals that you can't hear anywhere
else these books you can't get anywhere
else and these are sound books yeah year
listen on any device anytime anywhere
with the audible app it's great when
you're flying you're traveling around
the holidays whatever you want audible
got you covered and right now for a
limited time you get three months of
audible for just 695 a month that's more
than half off the regular price give
yourself the gift of listening and just
knowing stuff man
for more go to audible.com
/ k 80s yeah be that proper pigeon and
get out there and get what you need for
yourself you know a lot of times if you
can't read bro who cares dude I'm on you
bro readings for your eyes bro listening
is for your ears what do you think Floyd
Mayweather does yeah dude
honorable undoubtably so go there right
now get the limited time deal three
months of audible 695 a month more than
half off the regular price audible.com
slash cats or text K ATS 2 5 0 0 - 5 0 0
hey dude I do you know I just had a baby
yeah how about this is now I'm not just
making this up for the street how about
they go Oh popular you need some scrubs
I mean all right we'll give me some
scrubs they went we don't have any that
fit so they had to kind of makeshift
this Frankenstein scrub I'm like damn
you guys need more stylish man and
there's some little fine honey nurse
came I went thanks really
I went you have I'm hungry yep eggs you
ain't no fan what's figs tell me what it
is feel I'll tell you what figs is bruh
figs is a small fruit it used to be now
it's something beautiful and real kind
of like a drapery that full body health
drape dude yeah if you know somebody and
you're shopping for the holidays for
them and they are a nurse doctor dentist
somebody who likes to dress up like a
nurse or doctor or dentist for Halloween
somebody who likes to look like they are
a nurse even though they don't have a
job or licensed physician do this now
lice is verges and card carrier bro got
that word [ __ ] magician at a [ __ ]
halfway house oh yeah who cares figs is
for all a medical professional and non
medical profession yeah figs is an
amazing company that is making scrubs
stylish and functional for people who
deserve it most figs a F bro look man
you got to look nice why are you taking
care of somebody's baby or a zygote or
whatever why do they all look so weird
they don't have to anymore you like fly
as a nurse a doctor and figs also gives
back and you can't do every time you
shop at figs they give scrubs to health
care providers and needs around the
world
old gang [ __ ] but my sister works over
there at the urgent care over there by
Gonzalez dude and not and and she's
getting these things she's living my DM
was like check out my fish those are
cool I don't know why DME that pig film
yes you are oh yeah I got a husband
though but she got two husband she's
ever named Prairieville actually but
anyway she's getting the figs dude
everybody if you're a medical
non-medical you gettin fixed right
everybody can fix secret's out listen
and you get 50% off your first purchase
by using the code cats get ready to love
your scrubs head to where figs calm
that's W e AR f IG s calm enter the code
k 80s at checkout let's do this man
you guys want some more raps hell yeah
raps yes sir from The Andy Dufresne
collection like the boys are three
sisters I'm trying to clean this roof up
and needy boys trying to [ __ ] and I need
to frame collection oh yeah oh I'll
listen to this music close the door
they didn't have bad outfits did they
prison denim denim hell yeah can't hear
you knocking musics too loud he paid for
that though didn't he huh he paid for
that [ __ ]
you know what he did man got paid a
price though you feel me yeah what do
you got Dee well we got you little
browse remember I'm the champ yeah you
wanna so we got some he's the champ he
we got we got two more guys we're gonna
come for that spot because yeah cuz
lowbrows is number one do you want to
hear me gonna do you remember no I know
him loud I remember you let's go with
the new ones first and then yeah let's
go with the new house first you call no
brows right but first the contender mr.
Josh Duncan Jana
[Music]
no video no love it Costa King and see
in the snake
you
see a ctrl baby whoa lady like a teddy
brother Karsan Bailey over here
okay Josh Duncan feel good by some XE
from that man as well you don't have a
hand tat like that and not slang them
drop oh yeah
he did what effort though bro yeah man
he really went in there I feel like you
had a nice beat a nice backbeat
we're would see though no okay Miami
brah that's what I thought first that's
Miami dude right on a cloudy day real
sunny day possibly Fort Myers but I
think it was man that fair might be Fort
Lauderdale what else you got
we got up next the other contender black
mcbride ooh
my cannon black mcbride we are kairos
brother let's do a sick its Blasio you
are you're walking molars like you don't
slip in LA in the chorus you were
written never for us but do you I love
you still looking like a farmer written
looking lucky in the TV show Arthur
[Music]
[Music]
Blaze's Blazek what's 8 mile up in here
we got real battle rap thing going
let me know let me see the the number
one champ right now that's a blazing man
Blazek went in Brian I like the font he
had the the video font the black and
white tongue hit me with little brows
here for a second though get him brows
[Music]
[Music]
hey hey that's the chance we let the
fans vote right between him and the last
dude
they're both really good I think we let
the fan vote it's me tough to beat I
like the dudes selling acid on the
building though vote for all three
homeboy just stays you know Josh Duncan
26 I think we should put that up and
have the fans vote for the three they're
top yeah go boys hit hard yeah yeah they
all win Harmon I think some of the arm
the guy on the building made me nervous
a little but I like him I like anybody's
willing to throw some [ __ ] percocets
off a 70 story [ __ ] building bro yeah
he was something beautiful about that
that's a junkies [ __ ] snowfall mr.
John blue over there baby shut up the
305 yeah so I'll look at him but I think
we should let the fans vote so we tough
to beat that champ though he goes so
LASIK stayed in it how are we gonna post
him up we can put it up on Twitter okay
I'll bet spall but did pull on Twitter
mm-hmm
and then we you know we could do too is
you can we could create a little sizzle
reel of all three and post it to IG and
then tell them to go and vote on Twitter
yeah or you guys are guns are nice
people but also have bad ideas right now
why don't we put each one up on IG and
then make a thing a poll on idea where
they can go vote for their favorite is
it out of two or three it out of two for
IG polls though okay so what do you will
speak to than to go in I would say the
current champ and then the black and
white white boy Blazek is blazing that
blase it alright that's it then blazing
first browsers but now I'm not mad at
the [ __ ] earthquake 3:05 boy either
but of the two at the those were the
strongest yeah molest yourself they
carry yourself and look for the Lord
baby I love it
little browse and place so we'll go to
the tool post each one them up on IG and
their own spots on the wall you can
listen to them and then put the poll on
the story mm-hmm that's it is that the
show we got oh let's go we got a debate
club boy dude it's almost Christmas man
don't forget the white elephant gift
seether I got you done everybody brings
something they barely want don't be
showing up in a regular outfit like Alan
bring bring some Christmas [ __ ] this is
a nice Walker banger dude let's get real
here dress this [ __ ] give silk pajamas
for a Ghostbuster dude and you bring
sick ass Derrick no he's coming in here
like this bro yeah what's your carry on
brother emphysema brought that black
plague back with us from atomic I know I
liked him
he's losing color yeah yeah you gotta
get he'll yeah yeah that we can help you
at all yeah you need some bacon or a
couple milkshakes or something you gotta
get out the bra Danine happen what do
you got up next
Austin Gilbert there's a boy Austin
what's up fellas coming to you straight
out of Virginia I've got a debate club
for you that American gangster hitter my
man
Denzel Washington or Gang Gang those
dudes that boats indoors those clothes
boats and hoes shut up to these boys
damn that's a good one
Denzil watch them samuel l.jackson
Samuel Jackson these days bothers me
because he just does if it's okay to say
no sometimes any word from Capital One
now he's at the bank he's getting older
please I say yes to everything but dude
he's like the rock of black guys if you
make that if you made that much money
you're gonna end up at the bank it all
makes sense yeah you right depositing
checks Potenza watching doesn't make a
bad movie I liked what was the one where
he was the one where he was like badass
shooting everybody that made two of
electrolyzer dude he's wiser to the
planet nice 90 like Book of Eli was in
Ian's book of law yeah was good now all
his movies Oh Malcolm air call come on
bro was he that good a new training day
that's what I'm doing ask me were the
offices that you do where's the office
you're in the office he's in hot Denzel
oh yeah help me help me I look like an
endangered species uh for news easy
Denzel Washington all goddamn day
although Samuel Jackson almost saves in
Pulp Fiction well in mind if I take a
bite of your Kahuna burger yeah but
let's go back through some of Sammy J's
works man with some other beautiful
stuff that he's done Goodfellas drastic
park Goodfellas
he wasn't Goodfellas yes small role and
died real quick oh he played uh what's
that super Harry played in Oh mr. freeze
yeah no no
Frozone but he put somebody else to and
Avengers yes Nick Fury Nick Fury yeah
not like Nick Fury man yeah I'm going
Denzil in Django he really came through
with it man yeah bad and Jane do I
forgot about that
Pulp Fiction hey wait oh man let me see
dude I need some real layups - they do
better lover flubber
you know uh whatever that mother movie
wasn't you know I think he was in black
Annie - what else keep going down yeah
oh no he did a shaft that was great [ __ ]
with some [ __ ] the new one oh no no
he did the new one the old ones dope you
want some [ __ ] he did some makes on
a plane I'm going snakes on the plane
I'm going danzel man I'm going Denzel
all goddamn day
yeah dude Kong Skull Island Denzil -
it's not two L's is it
no just went out yeah Denzil are Denzil
57% Denzel yeah gang brah place ain't
got every movie - yep that's how good he
is is it yeah I just looked down like
that was shed you ever seen out of time
uh-huh name something else that he was
in uh what's that one movie the man on
fellas
oh man I'm fired not talking about
crystally is special no Denzel watched
all that name for a special command fire
Wow
cuz you reference it he talked Joe yeah
he's weeping a man on fire danced all
over that [ __ ] Brian was Denzel money so
dented bro Denzel that's what I'm
[ __ ] calling Chris now [ __ ] Denzel
Denzel Washington
everyone think Denzel though yeah it's
pretty close come on bro oh [ __ ] looks
like a coat rack in Fantasia that
[ __ ] oh sorry I keep making fun of
Britney but he won't make fun of me
today so I'm bugging his makeup honey
up next we got James Sullivan boys eh so
let's go boy the third also in the
course brother about
it's up the Oh what's up Brendon and
just talked to my brother he just met
Brendon and Philly he said he was a cool
dude
Brendan my Barber's hanging out with
Theo this weekend in Louisiana that's
weird and I'm sitting here on the road
with a flat tire got a debate question
for you fix it yourself or wait for
roadside Gang Gang bus rubbers oh yeah
boss robbers that's your nickname Derek
one bro well what car that is with the
red interior it has to be something
that's nice Maserati maybe anyway like
those [ __ ] no difference I come
hard I'm [ __ ] you don't know cars bro
dude I was [ __ ] born almost in a
Honda Civic Si our standard huh
that's Irish yeah it was kind of you
don't know girl you know she it was mid
grade you don't yeah whatever dude
hatchback huh no not a hatchback dude I
wouldn't be born in a [ __ ] hatchback
you would yeah it would have been nice
a little more room fixed I recalled cars
over dude first of all when you call for
service
it takes seven hours to get there just
fix that [ __ ] yourself dude do yourself
in and out yeah but if you get if you
call car service you can relax you could
talk to somebody could do work on your
computer I think it depends on what you
have left going on for out the day mmm
that's fair but also if you're on the
highway that shit's dangerous this [ __ ]
- I like being another way hmm do one
time my car broke down in New Orleans at
like a stoplight it was like a busy day
right and the Saints game was on on the
radio and it was coming down to it was
like the second half of the fourth
quarter and I was like I can't call help
now they're gonna come I have to deal
with all that [ __ ] so I just sat there
listening to the radio a real fan right
there hundreds of people honk and if
they win calling me names people call me
the n-word [ __ ] you just go make sense
but uh but man so I think there's time
and place to stay there and stay
stranded yeah yeah be careful but if you
don't have to fix a tire what are you
even doing how many dudes can actually
fix a tire these days can can he fix the
tire yeah you can without any better be
able to get tired you can build
railroad the longest time travel is this
middle nation or even a 3d gun look like
Carmen uh San Luis Obispo
Jim you look like you gotta get out here
to go collect at the Asian parlors
hatcher that's definitely you set your
gun on the table oh yeah oh but look man
I'll see you in uh I'll see you or
Vienna barber knows you said you and his
Barbara hanging out in some [ __ ] it
might have been where was all this
weekend I don't remember we're in
Louisiana I was at home I remember there
were no new Dateline no Shawn what the
[ __ ] bro can somebody die so he can get
some new dude Jesus they're just
remaking the old dead people um him
brauch and get out there and do some
work for you more obvious chin yeah um
no he said he's gonna see feel right
yeah yeah he says Barbara's gonna see
you in Louisiana in Louisiana okay well
we'll see I'll be here this weekend yeah
maybe I maybe we can yeah but just I'm
going home for the holidays yeah that's
what he's saying yeah I know your
schedule Goethe Barbara then I don't
know
remember Brutus the barber beefcake hell
yeah God dude remember we wrote him a
letter asked him to marry our mom when I
was young and they didn't they never got
married man hey can you look up that
picture Brutus the barber and respond
back and put beefcake at the end
sometimes like another guy comes up yeah
you don't yeah you'll be careful too
when he google beefcake beautiful - was
your mom into him when he had long hair
yeah she would honest we would notice
when watching wrestling
she's the only guy that he would stop
him she would stop you only pay
attention yeah yeah and sometimes big
bossman but he was really but so my mom
was a Elton John for whatever reason Wow
look at him
semi-retired dude that's basically
describes my erection most of the time
like that print tired check out his pink
coat of something very similar to that
pajama party for the Chicago Cubs no Jam
yes Brutus Beefcake
dude the bathroom but cake if you look
like one of the bash brothers that
caught AIDS
oh you mean skinny bash Ginny Betts yeah
[ __ ]
you mean thirsty bad you look like a
third bash brother
yeah bash on a little puppy all right
look man ah thank you for being good and
thanks for sitting in the video where we
can stay 76% went with fix that [ __ ]
yourself fix that [ __ ] dude and also
Manship a lot of men now instead of if
you don't want to take your wife or
something to another country is to try
and murder them they have the wife fix
the tire and then kick the jack over
while they're down there that makes
sense here's the other thing I think
about fellas you know snippet game it's
not lesbians know how to change tires -
so it's competitive dude get down there
get dirty otherwise [ __ ] Julie over
there gonna steal your girl
yeah he'll me otherwise for that same
haircut as Theo take your [ __ ] girl
brush wrong you leave utiful cut and if
you notice when I'm outdoors a lot of
birds will kind of look over at me I'm
not mad at it looks pretty nice day
would you use a nice conditioner maybe
water and air Oh cat what are you guys
doing your what do a lot of Vietnamese
people do when they have Auto issues we
bring into one of our uncle's everyone
has an uncle that's a mechanic mmm-hmm
you hear that Derek yeah Asians are
impressed what else you got little King
interesting it will wrap it up yeah all
right boys
first this is Shawn Rothwell supports
Shawn s row brah get it
what up Tito without Brandon hold your
corner what's up any guy can get her
sing it for you guys
true crime shows what do you think watch
that 441 blood
first 48 is my [ __ ] is it I always freak
out before everybody else it's pretty
pretty easy you know I'm saying
also they never finish that [ __ ] in 48
hours do they it's always like day seven
oh my god 48
no one ever failure 48 effort they never
figured out that fast was like six
months later
well [ __ ] dude gotta ruin the show and
then they tell you can't solve a crime
after two days after 48 hours so they
solving [ __ ] didn't realize how also you
realize how much snitches help I can't
do [ __ ] without people snitching yeah
they just go around looking for snitches
and everybody always has the craziest
nicknames in there yeah they're like oh
we found Squibb allowed here Chris
D'Elia has one of my favorite jokes ever
he goes have you seen the first 48 it's
a show where they have 48 hours to find
the killer but really they have as much
time as they want that's that's see
that's exactly what it is man months
later alright well [ __ ] dude
it's the best joke that's hilarious what
a mother favorite sad is got Larry read
whenever I was first started doing
comedy and he was out on the circuit and
he is this old polish guy and he'd be
like they tell me now that I answered a
phone during sex
Oh he goes my wife tells me never to
answer the phone during sex and he goes
but what if it's you call and that's
what he said that gets it the kids it
was for Nick anyway yeah I've done
everything dude mati you guys a bunch of
[ __ ] future hate crime victims
probably with the way your attitude is
first 48 me omit first or date me to mix
it up to get on the south bro it's the
same detective Oh Jerry's me stress yeah
like oh I remember when he's it I saw
one guy hit a stain on his shirt and I
remembered an episode three seasons and
he [ __ ] drip part of a food on his
shirt in the episode I'm like no crazy
man that guy what is this guy's a joke
true crime all day man right now I'm on
the Pyke's town murders man or pike Stan
I didn't read the title that much I just
clicked on it did you ever watch cold
case yeah but I've seen every cold case
yet I've seen every missing person I've
seen every disappeared I've seen
disappeared deleted scene do you know
what you see you'll disappeared I've
seen disappeared repackaged as the
missing I've seen what happens with the
case of Madeleine McCann they got the
baby I've seen what else dude where's
little Gregory brother French they
[ __ ] up dude they [ __ ] stole that
boy and then somebody's lying what else
have I seen bro Elizabeth Smart unseen
everybody I've seen the girl who goes to
a Dane Cook show her sister went to a
Dane Cook some went missing after Wyatt
and disappeared forever it's not a
documentary joke
I say let's go on vacation she was dead
yeah she knew one vic asian dude with a
murderer that's what you call it but
yeah i loved it man dark man
it gets dark yeah I'm sorry I brought a
dart you've got a lot of pain in my neck
today I think I've shingles bro I think
is my grandmother gave me this shirt
thank God you can feel your neck no you
know I'm saying yeah it sure is nice
what else you got
Tyler Illinois I think yeah I think it's
pretty heaven though we're some true
crime fans I love that you didn't name
any Brendan ah dude first 48 cold-case
files true detective
true detective not true detective I like
all of them you know but true crime
though you need mortis
suck my dick I'm sorry dick do I looked
over 50 yeah no ask Jim about Law &
Order
I like real [ __ ] brother yeah I want to
smell the blood yeah I want some real
[ __ ] I want to see [ __ ] Gary snitch
on his best friend then they're in the
[ __ ] in the room and they're both
getting life yeah I didn't mean I didn't
mean to man yeah dude it's some of the
people are
I just can't believe people just are
murdering each other dude just go home
and chill out you can buzz over some
random [ __ ] - yeah some of them I like
the seasonal ones right now I'm on
holiday homicide right now oh I like
that one - it's good but some of the
actors are just like just bad if I keep
you can't act like you're getting
murdered or whatever and then don't do
it
do you like did you watch cops growing
up oh yeah cops is crazy I think the
longer Sun TV show of all time
cops assailed it it's still pretty good
although it's a little weird when it's a
white captures a black guy and then the
camera cuts out there like he's cool man
we got him in the truck he's pretty beat
up very pretty
that's some of the earlier work yeah the
more recent work it's a lot more yeah
everybody's like nah he's actually
pretty cool man we just talked to him
and then he I guess he fell on his face
on the hood the car yeah the first
couple seasons it's just like a go it's
just a German Shepherd chasing a black
guy I feel like it was a little bit much
I felt like you know it seemed like just
a little like they definitely have some
white criminals you know yeah but they
weren't focused on him were there no but
I'd love to see him let the [ __ ] let
one of those German Shepherds loose on
the stock exchange floor and get some of
those [ __ ] taken people oh yeah
sick shout out the cops asked for a
cigarette but they're always in
handcuffs really telling you a cigarette
no and they're always like this off me I
should Ronnie
yep real oh and she was Ronnie usually
is done a crime Ronnie and that goes
that's all ethnicities - Ronnie is also
an Asian name isn't it
it is I like when they break down though
when they get busted for like the
seventh time up [ __ ] good
I was even involved in this well dude we
we literally saw you shoot that guy in
the face like [ __ ] nothing better and
then their life's over
that's like Donnie got 90 years in
prison and he's pretty crunk about it
just be on TV like oh what's up Dante
Charlotte mama what's happening yeah bro
you're going to jail for 70 years that's
right is that the most so far this is
gonna be the most played episode yeah it
is let's see this this guy looks like
he's in the air
what is this video coming in from Tyler
from Illinois it's that new Top Gun he's
on a windmill you know all those [ __ ]
things are yeah exactly how can you
google it there it is scary dude
whenever I see them I get nervous
finally well with Heights but they got
wind up there dude that's the scary part
- you gotta go all the way up there
guess what's up there wind it was scary
280 feet 180 feet you could make it if
you came off of that I've done 60 feet
you ever done like you're a jump out of
a cliff your athletic movement up with
your land feature dog is like you ever
tumble roll out of a glacier ton a 60
there's a dude in our town it was 75
feet he went up on this bridge was
talking all this [ __ ] he's like watch us
you little
eggs right and no offense if anybody
might be gay or their name is [ __ ] that's
just what he's that's I would never say
that we don't support them yeah he goes
watch this ye little gay people you know
and he jumped off if I can hit a boat
that was did he die
we're like do you [ __ ] up oh yeah
awesome oh yeah fine that's the same
that's like a real cannonball cannonball
no for reals cannonball wow man this is
awesome so this guy's one of those wind
workers man this guy's doing God's work
up there I don't do well with high it's
not for me
I'd love to get up there and put on one
of those things are you like those
little squirrel suits and just scoot off
that thing yeah take a date out chain
maybe you could take whoa you know what
bungee jumping in Mexico see who comes
back no sky jeepers alright
$7.00 to Akagi jumping if du / 1 du /
102 bungee jumping in Mexico they tie a
rope to you and you just run south of
the border man that's why what was this
question when okay bungee jump in Mexico
also known as Mexican rule at its
problems you'll survive is that
something you're interested in chin just
jumping out of anything dude I have a
skydiver inside it some friends of mine
that work down there great guys and it's
an amazing experience it's so easy to
just buzz down their time buzzing no way
I ain't jumping I'm playing the bro yep
the date I'm talking babe let's send him
on the date you down to do that chin why
not
because you look like you'll be real
scared but you can trust these people
man these people a lot of more former
military let them have served abroad no
they're too much living to do man but I
have kids that do it but your kids don't
want you to die doing something what die
what around the house [ __ ] driving to
the post office [ __ ] that it can't be
like hey Dad died because he wanted to
make sure Ching got his dick sucked and
we would I do that's a word too but what
he said
go to be supportive I'm not doing
anything with his wiener dude I'm not
either but that's the end goal here no
it is and I'm good
yeah he's not looking for anybody could
just jerk off near somebody's face while
he's looking for he's looking for love
you
you looking for a connection hunt Jen
yes he's 46 man okay you're right they
just may be just bungee jump in Mexico
dude if he and make us through that chin
he's forming it through anything bro bro
he's 46 and he's dressed like Willy
Loman on kedo
okay Russ bro okay yeah he looks like
[ __ ] look like if I can George
Michaels little sod bees in here yes
brother I say no one Iceman honestly
I've had some height instances where
when I used to do the road rules shall
we subdue Heights tongue runs really
well with I'm very good one time we had
a walk between two hot air balloons on a
plank oh and it was crazy huh for
ratings
no from I think $1500 Jesus so Kim a
long way bro yeah that's a good point
man it was crazy charmer and my legs I
couldn't even feel them I was so scared
so I just like I kept moving them from
the hip and just one for I can't I'm
getting sweaty talking about I can't do
it but those Heights camera motor I've
always want to do wing walking though
which is where you're on a plane wing
and you can walk out there because as
long as you're just on the wing you
don't fly off cuz you're with the plane
no never
not for me I'll start crying if I think
too much when I'm on an airplane really
yeah I hate it
damn it so no Heights for me good for
you they'll forgetting through it yeah
but it's scary Oh sometime I think it's
hit or miss you know so what are you
most scared of heights know if you can
do that like I fit I probably physically
couldn't do that the heights sometimes
it is it's like but you overcame it
there'd be tough for me to overcome that
yeah I'm scared of looking for something
in the dark when
if there's like a bunch of sharp glass
on the ground hmm yeah like I still turn
off my lights in my house and run up the
stairs everyone
I remember those wife's out of breath
lean know that being young I would get
as close as I could to the light switch
before I flipped it and there was one
two steps into bed you know yeah it was
yeah yeah
lag time yeah I remember that last night
Britten's son is putting him to sleep
Brendan's kids email he was like my
dad's got my bottom is that it brought
avoid 50 that's 50 wrong get in the can
dude next week when we do the Christmas
episode that will be officially be one
year yep
will it really one year of shenanigans
who knew we would start there and then
here it's true one year later come a
long way in one way got a long way to go
bro
amen brother she was getting good man I
like it here brother I preach all the
work you've been putting into man I
think people know the work you put in
behind scenes man well Nick's been doing
a ton too man and everybody's attitude
has been great so thank you bro but
kudos to Nick chin Kat Derek you yeah
we're doing our best you know doing the
damn thing shot all the Phantom in the
videos we have a bunch of new stuff
coming new year we'll talk about next
episode next week yeah we got a lot of
new stuff coming into new year but we
also have we are we've got the Christmas
episode coming up so do don't come don't
come dress like [ __ ] Chuck Norris
next week come correct bra Oh Christmas
dude what the only Jews in the house I
think Chinna that makes sense
do they have Chinese Jewish people I
think they do
I know Jewish people tend to love Asian
women so I think there's some Asian Jews
out there what is that I wonder I don't
know I really don't know but I mean
Asian women love white men so mm-hm do
that
shout out to it man right you're going
home this weekend Bey's power yep I'll
be heading home
yeah I'll be here for the holidays I'll
be down there with Dustin Poirier we're
doing that show at the Lafayette at the
Heyman Center and gonna be pretty cool
have fun at home man thanks man you two
what are you gonna do I'm in La Jolla at
the Comedy Store Thursday Friday
Saturday oh it's fine
hopefully Derek gets back to his normal
color I have put on good show I'll be at
La Joya Thursday Friday Saturday but my
babeh my favorite club man we just need
Derek to get healthy get healthy dude
also Sunday I'll be headlining his shows
are gonna sell out come to mind Sunday
oh yeah it's holidays headless headless
Pesci there so I started so it's a big
deal Sun gang pshh eight guys man buzz
buzz Gang Gang Gang okay oh you are
you're rocking molas like you Norma's
with the dead lay in the Taurus um
Brenda never bore us both be you I love
you see Oh looking like a farmer written
looking like he and the TV show Arthur
there what I do wanna saw you in my
camera can't City loves you looking like
a dim Fat Albert caddy you my girl I
just haven't told you yet I've been
waiting for the perfect time as perfect
as it gets
[Music]
there was us just waiting for chin to
get a date king in the sting will
thicken rabies coming to your town just
to spread some scabies holla holla
Brendan outta Colorado was a brawl in
our talk icky in singing in the momma
buzz-buzz